but we have to play dirty we have to
play the same games that the Democrats
are playing I'm sick of these weak ass
Republicans sitting back talking about
oh well well we are above that bullsh
we're gonna investigate a bunch of stuff
and have nothing come out of any of it
yeah yeah bullcrap above my ass we need
to we we we have to play dirty where's
Kevin McCarthy at what is Kevin McCarthy
doing if if people if if this was if
Nancy if people were going after Joe
Biden and trying to arrest him and Nancy
Pelosi if if if uh she was still the the
uh Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi
will be knocking doors down right now
yeah she would not be allowing
Republicans to go after Joe Biden she
would be punching back why are we not
doing the same they're way more ruthless
and with access to the media they come
out looking better than Republicans
every single time